A lower G.I.
endoscopy, also called colonoscopy or sigmoidoscopy,
allows your doctor to view the mucosal lining
of your lower gastrointestinal tract.
The procedure is used as a screening test
in individuals with no symptoms or to help
diagnose unexplained abdominal pain, rectal
bleeding, or a change in bowel habits.
It is capable of detecting inflammation, infections,
ulcers, diverticulosis, intestinal narrowing,
colorectal polyps, cancer, or other problems
that may be present.
Before the procedure you will need to undergo
bowel preparation.
Depending on the type of medication prescribed
to you, you will start 1 to 3 days before
the procedure.
You will need to modify your diet as well
as take medication, which will help to clear
your bowels in preparation for the procedure.
The procedure is performed using an endoscope,
which is a long, thin, flexible tube with
a light and a tiny video camera attached to
the end.
The camera transmits an image to a monitor.
In a sigmoidoscopy the endoscope only reaches
to the top of the descending colon.
In a colonoscopy the endoscope reaches through
the entire length of the colon, to where it
connects to the small intestine.
The presence of the endoscope and the air
may cause you to feel cramping or pressure
and the need to pass gas.
This is considered a normal part of the procedure.
Your doctor may ask you to change your position
slightly to help maneuver the endoscope more
easily through the curves of your lower intestine.
If you experience pain, tell your doctor immediately.
In some cases, your doctor may find it necessary
to take a biopsy.
A biopsy helps distinguish between benign
and cancerous tissues and can help determine
the cause of bleeding, inflammation, or diarrhea.
Biopsies are often taken, even when your doctor
does not suspect cancer.
If one or more polyps are discovered, your
doctor will generally remove them in a procedure
called a polypectomy.
He or she will usually use a snare to remove
the polyps and then cauterize their bases
to control bleeding.
At the end of your procedure the endoscope
will be removed from your colon.
A sigmoidoscopy usually takes about twenty
minutes, while a colonoscopy can take thirty
minutes to an hour.